Plato once said, "Seek truth while you are young,..."
"...for if you do not, it will later escape your grasp."
Recently, a conference in Rome studied the broader implications of Plato's quote.
The conference was called "Philosophy as Paideia,"...
...a reference to the well-rounded education of ancient times.
Participants discussed how to think...
...but also how to teach the discipline in a more practical way.
For example, for a doctor, philosophy is useful for reflecting on what makes someone human...
...or what suffering means.
Philosophy can even help an engineer.
An engineer can use a different mindset to think about a technique or what it means.
The professors believe that philosophy helps develop self-esteem and personality.
They say it is crucial for a young person's formation.
We see that there is a very present demand for philosophy,...
...which is basically a desire to know.
And you don't expect it but people need this.
The Pontifical University of the Holy Cross organized the conference.
It drew an international group of businesspeople, teachers and philosophers.